and I think it would be entirely
appropriate wasn't member this committee
just to remember Chris black so I
thought you asked everybody sustaining
[Music]
thank you so much right going to the
minutes of the last meeting is it your
wish that I song there's a true record
okay great thank you
I think thank you
all right first item on the item on the
agenda the news item 6 which is the
progress reports over to members they
can't went over to four is in group but
Hermes come along tonight so yeah I
think it will be problem given that
there's not much on the agenda oh no I
went with it um
I'm talking ahead on the road yeah I'm
talking to
I've ever had but we've got 21 pages
meant this first one is about the public
toilet strategy I think there any
questions on that
most of the stuff if you think as you
know ingre is done issues on the
petition raised which were resolved and
you'll review furbished and construction
new public conveniences which again is
the toilets PC safety helps good to hear
that's going ahead over eighty police
station so that's great doesn't if you
want to say anything about that's all I
mean Danny it's like this one is that
it's been delayed like what you do to
the the police themselves having some
health and safety issues relating to
actually co-locating their staff with
council staff so it was originally due
to start in July and that's now been
pushed back to December the earliest of
disser Lea the better obviously yeah so
is nearly started frustrating in terms
of how that's that slipped and that is
down to the police just having extra
shoes a 1080 that's fine okay thank you
for that right on the N 615 we've got
the acid review project options which
hasn't have been resolved please stop me
if anybody wants to raise anything at
least at one three two London Road open
space program
so me busy local reports of seven wait
for it business rates father rather they
think he didn't having has has cotton so
it I think it'd be wrong to not that uh
talk us through this idea so this item
it's not more decision as such it's more
information and so it's about their
greater Essex business rates pilots bid
that's now being submitted as at last
Friday there was quite a tight deadline
to get the bidding so obviously
discussions in Council on concepts I'm
excited and so present and participation
as part of that bed one point to note
and that slightly differs from the paper
is that unfortunately thorak and decided
to withdraw from the ledger at the last
moment so rather than all sixteen Essex
authorities and sent it up being the 50s
all of the districts accounts a
fireplace and stuff end but so just just
not including mammoth or ik so that was
the bit that was submitted to D CLG and
so just to sort of then backtrack side
on what the bid is actually about so as
you're aware and as a bidding Authority
we collect all the business rates across
the the districts and we get to keep
sharing
business rights at the moment ruptured
his part of a pool with a number of
Essex authorities not all of them
essentially that allows us to keep a
greater share of those rights within
within the district so it's a beneficial
arrangement for us and the pilot that
the government's forward they're
basically what they call functional
economic areas to put forward proposals
for a hundred percent business rates of
tension eyelets that essentially means
that we would get to keep a greater
share of our business rates so basically
all of the authorities and well apart
from the end felt it was beneficial
beneficial for us to be part of this
part of this pilot agreement so yeah we
submitted a bit sad ECoG we should find
out around the time as a local problem
and sentiment whether we've been
successful or not if we are successful
it could be quite beneficial for us
financially we know exactly how much
we'll get because obviously all
dependent on exasperate to actually take
it could be in the region of about
400,000 pounds potentially that would
only be for one year initially because
of the the pilot would just be for 1819
but there's potential to extend it and
you obviously the reason that the
government wants this or pilot this
arrangement is because they're looking
forward to the future and all local
authorities having more financially
self-sustaining and members of 2021
onwards so they're looking at ways to
you know distribute funding by this sort
mechanism so you know from the pilot
areas to get up space either source how
many the position about I don't think
it's because they only be part of a
different pilot area and they're
currently in a pool with Basden and the
London bars but the lungs and for the
Greater London area is going to have its
own pilot and essentially so they can't
actually fault be part of that one so we
think it probably was for political
reasons but we haven't really and the
officers involved were quite keen to
participate I think it was a political
decision at the last minute they don't
want to participate but we don't really
have any i'm just think i mean that
along with any pilot we know that there
will be certain but two burdens but no
extra duty shows they placed upon us and
perhaps they're shy of those because we
don't really know they can baby activity
but if any but you know that's wait the
scene when i have a chance to speak to
the leader there and what yeah I'm
sexual responsibilities and for the
pilot we shouldn't actually be getting
any extra responsibilities at this stage
that their grants vessels and rolling
into the arrangement our revenue support
grant which we were Kenny
anyway Adams also wrong services from
which again we might manageable for that
grant so as a unitary authority would it
be the same for them as well and so they
would have had probably some more
revenue support I'm still not very much
but a bit but they still would have been
fine actually better and there's
something catastrophic happens so it I
don't think it's probably for financial
reasons they chose to interesting
I'll take sign of danger no no it's
something I was the question I was going
so II I think about them
so that's alright know about like first
are not having you mean with the what
hopefully when you get the business
Raisa there's also going to be shared
out with county police and fire where
parish is fitting to this scenario will
they because they said to their own
precinct will they be able to call on
this at all or will there be anything
there does we have to be outside
no they're basically outside of this
sort of funding arrangement so necessary
precepts and obviously some of these
duties to and districts to miss people
maybe that's their parishes as well but
they said there's no fall and wrongful
crashes as part of this arrangement no
thinking yeah yeah yes she's just
blanked up a very interesting dynamic
visibly 2015 and the CGSA and how and
our memorandum others
and that's just that's pretty
interesting well he's been the twist
like that you don't know I don't know
ideas pure conjecture really yeah
but you know I mean the moment she said
I thought to myself because they are
looking to put in so many businesses and
such like in many ways yeah yeah is
there a case where they are feeling that
that's gonna be the main on some heavy
area as opposed to atop every area a
bottom heavy area or business in you
know going in I won't be getting the
lion's share the business rights and
sharing whereas I think the whole pop
themselves in she conjecture I mean if
you think about rocks for this case I
mean we've got things like the airport
the exact business pal think we'll get
more out of this need we were in a pool
before as well but you know it's you
know I mean as far as the agenda is
concerned you know there's I can't see
any problems at all about this and how
much you know it's really just for
noting anyway you've obviously we will
wait until we get the details in
December there's usually a very short
time isn't there in December before
before Christmas yes so you mean yeah
they always do that like and I think I'm
right in saying next year the accounts
have got to be done months earlier
deadline and where we have to get
yy-yeah issues so good luck with that
but there's no different I suppose what
you face them County it's a bit more
complex isn't it so there's no bones
really being successful I think maybe
although I think I need to do piety and
yeah it's quite high indeed anybody else
know okay in members don't report very
much and in the last one is you Mike by
night is the the award for voluntary
sector brass it's great that they're
being able to do this as well yeah
nothing's he's very welcome that we
could continue this for this next
financial year I think there's a huge
number of voluntary organisations in
what should that have benefited from
this in the past and certainly you
believe the appendix to this document
lists the large number of organizations
in watchbird that have received grants
from watcher council via valves and some
of the excellent work that's taking
place in this district so I'm really
pleased that we're going to be able to
continue with this albeit with a
slightly different split now between
revenue and capital funding but I
certainly welcome this report and the
impact that it will have on our
communities again as Mike said I think
this is in difficult times showing a
great commitment to our local community
and the people who work within it to go
over and above what many ordinary
members of public do in terms of
practicalities what we're essentially
doing it at this moment is a between the
process and the money
however the formal allocation
the money will happen a budget so that
we do have that last bit of flexibility
should some catastrophe happen and I
think it's important that it always is
formally agreed a budget time so that we
do have that bit of movement but the the
grants process work will open fairly
soon and even the bigger organizations
aren't looking at any any sort of cut at
this moment in time I think we do it
early because the impact assessment
don't we yes but I think it would be
wrong for us to be allocating next
year's budget in advance of nature's
budget being set and as a protocol
that's important I know administrative
lead the financial year is the financial
year however let us say there was some
sort of catastrophe and we couldn't do
it well yeah then we announced and other
people would have to work to our our
timing they want to change it you want
to check thank you and please yeah thank
you very much Jennifer
I noticed that hunt works has got an
allocation and that's an eight point
seven I'm actually very pleased that was
last year this is last year just now we
don't know what's going to go forward
look I mean in regards to how it works I
mean they've been very supportive of all
the work that's been going on in France
is kotti in hills and things and you
know and I think again they're working
very very closely you know with us to
help out especially the people have been
made homeless and trying to get them in
so you know I would have just a flag up
in people's minds with regard to the
work that they are doing and
it's perfectly right and I think it's
something that we need to make sure that
we put on our website because I mean
I've given stuff to hope works they do a
very good service and they you know they
nobody normally refurbish and then you
have reissued and it's quite a lot of
stuff that they didn't work with that
child wasn't aware of at the time and to
actually use them so I think it's good
but there are other people like Sue
Ryder and others that good et cetera so
I think you know this as far as those so
we said less fortunate or whatever are
concerned I think they're already good
and that that could be part of what
we're looking at here I mean it's all
sort of contributing to the voluntary
sector and if we can sort of lubricate
that much better than we do absolutely
what's wrong with that but it's up to
them to put billion obviously and the
proper and appropriate lead shall we say
to take it forward so that let's see how
that goes anybody else want to come in
at all yes please
so we're going to minimum 5,000 capital
and there's also the maximum yeah well
you see what they see what the Queen's
coming on it you've got to spread the
jam a bit I think we get it yeah we'll
be judged on it's married to an
objective score written system
administered by by officers in the first
instance and subject to review by
committee the DAR chair which normally
consists of the the various group
leaders so there's a complete
objectivity on fairness and so I think
the chairman TT text part as well
doesn't she because from him yeah yeah
and I think the chairman check in use
the checkbox well I think once I'm a
don't recall my yes yeah I give out an
old boy a long time but I think the
other thing is that our community
section does Andrew likes team if you
like he's not just about this either
it's about signposting to other ones
there are available
things like CIF communities in a
structure funded cetera
and I think that's a good use of
resources as far as we're concerned I
remember when you contribute to the
voluntary sector you usually get more
out of it than you put into it yeah
because you're you're gaining extra
extra you know the human element chewy
site coming forward but nevertheless
some of these things cost a little bit
of money so that's that's the way it is
so I think as far as that's concerned it
works very well now very often some of
those monies will attract other monies
as well so you you multiply out your
money so any other comments please that
members a green report
thank you very much I think that ends
the proceedings this evening so thank
you very much if you want